okay new game
oh she she randomly gained five years in
age like the movie
or the series
like she goes from being just a
non-threatening
child to becoming a slightly more
threatening teenager
rated 1880 okay
oh and then oh wait wait she goes from
1880 to 2400
in two years
what okay um
let's start with this so challenge time
random color let's go
oh i keep forgetting she's she's trash
talking me
i just haven't been looking at the thing
uh
do i i could play a stafford
wait she she's oh no wait that's not
true
[Music]
wait she's playing a king's gambit do
you even know the name of your
netflix series okay let's play an album
counter gamut
bam
have you really seen this or this is not
alvin counter gambit this is uh
this is folk beer counter gambit so this
is like a
flipped version of what borgoth played
against her
have you really seen this before
because i've seen it before too and i'm
pretty booked up
a queen e2 queen e2 is maybe playable
but looks kind of bad because bishop f5
another the queen's blocked in you can
take my pawn if you want
oh
i'm losing i'm losing another pawn but
this is kind of the spirit of the gambit
i'm gonna lose a pawn wait what she's
not taking the pawn
she's scared maybe
what to do here i couldn't like
chase around the queen but
let's complete development i don't care
about this pawn
wow b4
very baffling
wait this is complicated so i want to
play a6
and then takes and then rook a7 but the
queen
like weirdly escapes
so i could play bishop d4
i also have to be concerned if the
bishop moves there's this move
threatening the
other bishop
and what is this witchcraft there's a
weird line bishop d4
g6 c5 or bishop d4 d6 bishop g6
let's do this
man i saw that coming too
how to cope with this
okay i have options i mean we're
probably going to end up trading the
pawns
or i'll play c5 and things will get
weird
let's play c5 i think things are getting
weird
wait that's that's too weird for me
that's a free bishop
did she forget bishop's
move diagonally after playing a diagonal
bishop move
oh that's not a free bishop i forgot my
i'm getting skewered
i'm trash talking too much why is this
move
these lines don't work
okay
i'm so confused here so i could
i could chase the queen away from the
fifth rank
the problem is i if i play a6 the queen
just goes back and defends the bishop
but then i could attack the queen
further like a6 queen a4 b5 queen b3
bishop e6 queen b2
and then b4 oh look at this line
so a6 queen a4
b5 queen b3 bishop e6
queen b2 queen has to say defending the
bishop
and then b4 it's a fork bishop takes b4
rook b8 it's a pin
then a3 and then a5 bam and i win the
bishop in the end
let's do it
oh that's not that's not what i
considered
but i'm happy with this i'm happy with
this because now i can take the bishop
and i'm up i'm up material
but she wants to fork me
in various weird ways i could take a
pawn
oh you know what she wants to do she
wants to take my rook
say oh no my queen and then fork and
then
that would be unfortunate so i can dig
upon
defending c7
yeah she stopped talking
probably because she has nothing nothing
trashy to say
this move is kind of kind of scary
though okay let's take a
no if i take the knight if i take the
knight my bishops got forked
um
you can play queen b8
it feels weird
but sometimes you gotta do what you
gotta do
okay
man that's annoying she keeps like she's
down material but she keeps attacking me
and it's so easy to blunder like if i
move my bishop back i get
i get trapped
i could play g6 but then g4
am i losing a bishop here that's insane
if i have no way to defend the bishop
oh i have an idea look at this idea
oh but maybe it doesn't work a crazy
idea bishop
e6 f4 bishop takes a2
idea being rook takes a2 queen b1 king
f2 queen takes rook
the problem is my rook hangs in the end
and potentially my other rook
so i don't know what to do the question
is how i save the bishop
maybe bishop g6 and then no but still g4
and queen b2 is interesting
man i thought it was gonna be easy once
i won the bishop
but it's not so easy
and i'm not looking at chat i'm sure
chad would know what to do
chat always knows what to do
what's a pawn count i'm down two pawns
but i have the piece
so one benefit if i do allow f5 i could
win this pawn and then check on g3
not sure how much that does
another idea
[Music]
is to include bishop e5 to attack the
rook
but that doesn't really do so much
wow
oh i haven't oh no it doesn't work i was
thinking takes takes and then queen e5
my rook again hangs it's such an awkward
position
[Music]
i don't know why i got myself into this
this
[Music]
mess okay one more time g6
maybe g6 is the way to go because then
g5
and i can win a pawn and then takes and
then takes and then takes and then takes
then the game goes on okay
had to choose something oh
wait what i analyzed all that
this has happened a few times this game
i'll analyze like a deep
idea and or deep line and she'll play
something else
okay i should be winning now i just have
to figure out how to
deal with the awkwardness of the queen
and rook probably castling
never too late to castle
okay now queen b2
yeah let's play queen b2 and bishop c5
everything defends everything
hmm
okay so she can't castle
could maybe play this
let's move threatening rook b6
oh rook b6 hangs a rook let's not
blunder
let's play e3 going for the destruction
here we go it's getting weird again
can take
okay but we're trading this is good
i was ready to play queen b5 check
okay let's simplify it should be easy
win
that was a weird difficult game
at least difficult like opening middle
game type thing
she says this check doesn't scare me
you have more things to be scared about
than checks
oh she keeps saying that
that's not going to change your destiny
do i knight bishop mates
no
[Music]
all bishop bishop night night mate
do i i could let's do it
i i haven't had fun in so long
wait where'd whites oh white's king kind
of disappeared there
mine a piecemeat [ __ ] yeah get ready
for it
get ready for it do i have all auto
queen turned on
i better not have auto queen turned on
oh alexa stop it i'm reminding you
turn on i know the fridge is off
how i disable auto queen is it
controller alt
just hold down both wait let's not
stalemate
i can promote tonight
and then bring the other pawn
let's go
i'll promote to a bishop
hold down alt again uh
yeah i'll have all my minor pieces
and now i just have to orchestrate some
beautiful checkmates
with all of them
wait what the king's escaping no
how's the king escaping no the pawn's
escaping too
where's my mate
i'll let her queen how about wait how do
i mate here
in the most beautiful fashion
king i have to compose a study
this looks good enough here
very very funny wait what she said i'll
take a new queen
and she underpromoted to a rook
does she not know the difference between
the chess pieces
i guess she's right about good game
it's about to be over look at this
bishop g1
have to save her the moment
i'm just having a nice party
and then i can do oh
you can do this move so that's check
and that's counter check am i going to
mate
or just trying to provoke a weakness
you're trying to provoke me to checkmate
you
let's go haha okay
that was very satisfying got the minor
piecemates
okay
oh she's never lost a serious game
until now that was very serious
okay that was nice
i mean that's the finish was kind of
unnecessary but also beautiful